I've got my first two pieces of
information that are important I don't
know what you called them it doesn't
matter all that much what you call them
so long as you call them something and
that what you've called them make sense
to you and is instructive I've got the
first year of sales I got the annual
growth and then they pose a question I
think they say in which is it in which
year do the annual sales first exceed I
think it's a million dollars isn't it in
which you do the sales first exceeded
million dollars so just like we saw
before some formulas or some questions
rather require the nth term other ones
require the sum of the first n terms so
which one is this going to be is it
going to be a servant or - mm-hmm read
it read it again if you're not sure it
says in which you do annual sales first
succeed right so when they say annual
sales they mean a particular year one
year and only one year so that tells you
if this the nth term not the sum of the
person in terms we're going to come to
the sum in the next question okay so I'm
just going to write T of N equals and
have you think have you thought about
this sum this guy here right see that 20
percent it means that you're going up by
a different amount each time the further
you are in the future the more you're
growing by so this is not an AP this is
a GP as we pointed out before so that's
why I'm going to use a different formula
dad okay now I've just written this down
not because this gets me any marks but
it just gives my brain of scaffold to
hang the numbers on that I need okay now
don't write this down just yet strictly
speaking strictly speaking probably the
the most technically correct way to
write the next line is to say I want
this thing a are it to the N minus 1
I want to exceed in any dollars right
I want to exceed million dollars so
strictly speaking I should write this do
you see that like I want that nth term
to be more than a million dollars okay
and there's no reason why you can't do
that you'll come out with the answer of
yet today here's a number and you'll be
fine however for reasons that I'm going
to try and justify in about I want to
say three but it's maybe four lines I'm
going to not do that instead of
forming an inequality even though the
question is about inequality I'm going
to just stick with an equation it ends
up making things a bit simpler so just
stay with me and I'll try and justify
why okay a and R
I know what these are I know what these
are they're the two things that I wrote
down up above kind of so I want a two
hundred thousand x art now just be
careful
what I'm going to put in here is not
twenty percent because if I multiply by
20 percent I'm getting smaller and
smaller and smaller as well actually I'm
growing right so I'm not mocking by
multiplying by 20 percent I'm
multiplying by a hundred twenty percent
that's what makes it bigger okay so
instead of a 120 I'm gonna write it as a
decimal one point two it's just faster
and um it's less things to write down
because 120 percent of course means 120
divided by 100
okay now n minus one that's a bit I
don't know so I'm just gonna leave it
there and now what I'm gonna imagine is
suppose there's a year where I'm exactly
equal to a million dollars I actually
want to know when it's more than a
million dollars but this is gonna make
things easier to solve for me on the
next couple of lines I want to simplify
a little more and I can see there's this
huge common factor on both sides so I
will divide by 200,000 that gives me
this and now think back to the last
topic that you do when you have a look
at a question like this what knowledge
do we use to solve such a question we
use logs right so there's a couple of
things you could do at this point
probably the simplest would be just to
rewrite this exponential equation as its
equivalent log equation which should be
n minus 1 is the power is log now which
one is the base and which one is the
other number that comes after so if you
can't remember where the nice ways to
sort of give you a mental hook is to say
the base here will become the base here
that make sense and then the rest of the
numbers just go in whatever spots are
left so I've got one point two here and
five okay just quickly another way to
know this is to say okay this is the
number that I'm growing from and that's
what logs mean like when you have log
base B
you're growing rate well 1.2 is my
growing we're in this case as it happens
I don't have a log base 1.2 button on my
calculator so I've got to do something
else here in order to actually work out
what this number is
so you vote you calculator there what
are you going to do with this to make it
usable by your calculator yeah a change
of base law so you could choose any base
you like you've got base 10 and base e
on your calculator I am lazy so I'm
going to write one little s which is
base e and I've got the five on the top
and the 1.2 on the bottom okay
I don't actually want n minus one I want
and so I will add one to both sides is
that okay
right now range for your calculator it
should give you a number what do you got
okay and then have you added one you've
got a point that's that's this number
right so nine point eight seven or
something like that is that right yeah
say yeah eight to seven da-da-da-dah
okay now put your pen down for a moment
and think with me if I had written this
as an inequality right at the beginning
right at some in some ways I would have
my answer now right because I'd say
excuse me an has to be greater than nine
point eight so the next year is going to
clearly be ten and there's your answer
year 10 year 11 year 12 all of them
would exceed a million dollars because
you just get bigger and bigger and
bigger now what was the reason why I
chose to write an inequality rather than
sorry an equation rather than inequality
where would I have written it I would
have written it here I already said I
want this to be greater than I want this
to be greater than but they just look
carefully at what happens here okay now
when you change from a log equation
sorry an exponential equation to a log
equation you have to be really careful
about what goes on each side if you have
an inequality does that make sense
because in an inequality the two sides
are different
that's what inequality means right so
you can't just put the wherever you like
and students what I find is they get
confused about which way they should
write it and they're like there's this
one going this side or that side and
then
can get an inequality at the end which
is actually incorrect right all of them
all the maths all the numbers are
correct but they've just written the
equations backwards okay now we can
escape that and this is why I did this
we can escape that problem by just
sticking with an equation write an
equation both sides are identical
that's what equation means so therefore
it doesn't matter which way I write
these round I just have to interpret
this answer at the end okay so now I can
conclude I can say therefore after ten
years would be my answer well at the end
of the temptu you just check the
weighting of the question and it'll tell
you wait now just one final note I drew
over here this little set of axes you
don't have to draw it but if you want
just draw a quick and dirty one on the
side the reason why we come up against
this weirdness down here then we have to
interpret the answer and be a little
careful with it is because we're doing
something which is called modeling now
we've looked at models before back when
we were doing max min and we're like
here's a situation we'd like some piece
of wire and you want to make a fence out
of it or something like that right now
what we've done here is we've used a
model which is what we call a continuous
model it's continuous because have a
look at which is the line um after this
line here have a look at this line okay
it's an exponential function and
exponential functions as you know just
look like that it's one continuous
function right and it's got no brakes
but we're using a continuous model to
describe a discrete not with a double in
which means like Shh discrete discrete
with two separate e's means it's
separated out you've got like integer
values like there's this year and then
there's the next year and there's no in
between right so we're using this
continuous model to describe a discrete
situation and there isn't any exact year
where there's exactly a million dollars
as you're coming out right if I went to
go one two three four five six seven
eight nine ten
etc right if you looked for a million
dollars it would be between
at 9.8 to 7 but there is no such year
and that's why I use this number and I
go to the next year does that make sense
no getting at this why not making a big
deal about this getting at this will
tell you the difference between do I
just round like this happens to round up
or actually depending on the situation
depending how your model relates to the
actual thing you're trying to solve
sometimes you will round down sometimes
you'll say 9 years even though that
clearly rounds up because you're trying
to solve a different kind of problem
with your model does that make sense
we will come to those examples later on
and I'll point them out to you know wave
a big flag just so you know or this is
strange and unusual but I'm just trying
to point out the fact that it comes from
us using sort of I'm not quite right
tool for the job but it's the closest
one we've got ok does anyone any
questions happy